dozens of South Koreans are in North
Korea this week reuniting with family
members they've been separated from
since the Korean War
the emotional and time-limited reunion
is being held at a mountain resort north
of the border between the two countries
then Tracy joins us from the South
Korean capital Seoul with more on this
rare and happy event than good morning
good morning it has now been three years
since the last round of the reunions of
separated families took place and time
is really running out for a lot of
Koreans who are now in their 80s and
their 90s so this small group is now
meeting their long-lost relatives for
the first time in decades but sadly they
also know it will be the last time they
meet this is what it looks like when a
92 year old woman gets to hug her son
for the first time in 68 years he is now
71 in like everyone in this room they
were separated during the bloody Korean
War which split the peninsula in two in
1953 this brother and sister could not
contain their emotion as they embrace
for the first time in decades this part
in his face just looked like our father
said this North Korean woman this week
of reunions was one of the main
agreements made by South Korean
president moon jae-in and North Korean
leader Kim Jong moon at their April
summit it's been a moment of relative
stability on the Korean Peninsula even
though there are no signs that North
Korea has actually decided to abandon
its nuclear weapons program but for the
people in this room none of that matters
they are here to make up for lost time
learning how their relatives have spent
their lives just a few hundred miles
away this 82 year old from South Korea
was reunited with her two sisters I
expected my sisters to be dead but they
are alive and well she said many brought
photographs of their extended families
even if it was sometimes difficult to
recognize each
even if he's gotten old and has wrinkles
on his face there is still some of him
left in his appearance said Kim Jung
sung-hoon ighting with his North Korean
brother now there are thousands of other
Koreans who have not been picked to
participate in one of these reunions
here in the South they're actually
chosen by a lottery but in North Korea
it's believed that they're actually
chosen for their loyalty to the
authoritarian regime they're John Ben
Tracy in Seoul thanks the images of them
holding hands
yeah after such separation and not
wanting to let go again mother seeing
her baby even though he's 70 something
years old and the lifestyle that will
always enter your baby I know I saw you
crying
those tears coming I remind you how
important your family is yeah what we
take for granted here yeah